the Charlotte Mecklenburg Schools in
North Carolina are apparently promoting
a gay sex guide to seventh graders
here's a mother showing up to a school
board meeting just reading and I have
instructed by the way our editor is to
bleep this very very liberally because
it's actually scandalous and obscene and
I don't want to expose my listeners to
it but this is the sort of thing that
seventh graders are being exposed to in
their schools in Carolina
this book is gay by Juno Dawson was
found in a seventh grade classroom at
collinswood Middle School it was also on
the ELA recommended reading list for
seventh graders at J.M Robinson I'm
going to read from chapter 9 the ins and
outs of gay sex starting at page 201
part one boy on boy sex perhaps the most
important skill you will Master is a gay
or by man is a Timeless classic the hand
good news is you can practice it on
yourself the bad news is each guy has
become very used to his own way of
getting himself learning how to find a
partner's personal style can take ages
but it can be very rewarding when you do
a good is all about the wrist action rub
the head of his back and forth with your
hand try different speeds and pressures
until he responds positively a bad
hideous grasping and shaking it like a
ketchup bottle it's no wonder that 92
percent of CMS graduating seniors aren't
college or career ready when you're
instructing them on how to give blood
and instead of teaching them how to add
and subtract superintendent you stated
this book was quote brought into the
classroom by a teacher with no intent to
allow students access any teacher that
puts material like this on his or her
belt shelf either a bad teacher or a
pedophile who Grooms children
two minutes are up here Here Lady here
by the way I I cut out some of the most
obscene Parts okay that wasn't and I I
don't mean to laugh at it I mean she's
she has a very good point she says you
know maybe if these kids spent more time
learning addition and subtraction and
less time learning about gay sex maybe
their test scores wouldn't be so bad but
the one that really got me is the
ketchup bottle line and I think this is
I don't mean to laugh but it's so it's
so absurd you wouldn't you wouldn't
believe this
if you hadn't heard it I wouldn't
believe this had I not heard that and I
and I'm relatively young and it's I I
was in school relatively recently and so
I know how crazy things have gotten but
constantly when I'm talking to friends
and relatives and just people when I go
give speeches who are in their 50s 60s
70s 80s sometimes they don't believe
that this stuff is actually happening
but you just you just heard it this is
in schools that book which reads like a
cartoon caricature of gay porn is in
seventh grade classrooms it's on it's on
recommended reading lists okay
that is obviously insane and then I love
the defenses that obviously dishonest
defense is that well no the teacher just
brought it in for what his or her own
reading pleasure that's creepier that's
even creepier than bringing it in as a
learning material because then you've
just got a teacher reading gay porn in a
seventh grade classroom surrounded by 12
year olds just what to titillate himself
that's that's even creepier but
obviously it was this part of a teaching
material that's why I was on a
recommended reading list
and and then so obviously these teachers
should be fired the book should be
banned from the schools this is just
complete the school board should resign
if they tolerate this obviously that
goes without saying put that aside for a
second
to the woman's point at the end this is
such an important reminder about the
nature of sin and vice
sin corrupts your soul yes it leads you
down the road to Perdition yes it has
these distorting perverting effects on
your metaphysical self
another big
problem with sin
is that it's such a waste of time
all sin is just such a waste of time
when you could be doing good things and
edifying things and sanctifying things
you instead do things they're bad and
corrosive and just a waste of time think
about the precious time that you you're
12 years old your brain is so malleable
you you could be learning foreign
languages you could be learning
trigonometry you could be learning
history and dates and facts and things
that are going to help you to be
learning to write and and important
things in your life
and then that precious time is being
wasted
learning about how to how to
how to handle yourself and your friends
like a ketchup bottle
what what a
dark sad
in a way kind of funny
waste of time don't do it you will die
we were just talking about epic will you
will die someday don't when you when you
get to the accounting at St Peter's gate
okay and you have to account for your
whole life yeah there's the good stuff
and the bad stuff but then just think
about the waste of time like yeah I
decided in those precious moments of of
beautiful life that I was given I
decided to read read about the ketchup
bottle don't do that do not do that the
rest of the show is continuing now there
are uh fake headlines that we need to
we need to work through today okay this
is Friday on Friday it's fake headline
day Davies picks out five headlines for
a real one is fake I had had a perfect
score
now I don't I got it wrong last week I
need you to help me in the comments
section to pick out which one is the
fake headline you don't want to miss it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us see you over
on the member block
[Music]
oh
foreign